President Biden facing criticism for
seeing a sanitized version of the Border
during his first ever trip there he's in
Mexico now and is about to meet with the
country's president after spending a
total of four hours on the ground in El
Paso Texas but it's what Biden didn't
see that is causing the most controversy
just days ago the city was overwhelmed
with migrants sleeping on the streets
when Biden arrived they were all gone
the President also taking heat for
avoiding the migrants themselves that is
despite border patrol sources telling
Fox they encountered more than 500
illegal immigrants in the El Paso sector
yesterday Biden is now calling the trip
a learning experience
weapon
they make a lot of resources
and one of the most notable moments of
the trip happened when Texas governor
Greg Abbott hand-delivered President
Biden a scathing letter about the Border
crisis it accuses Biden of emboldening
the cartels Abbott is also Furious over
accusation that Biden's visit was
whitewashed
he was receiving a sanitized review of
what was going on in the border and I
pleaded with him to go talk to the
ranchers thousands of ranchers along the
border whose lives have been completely
disrupted so it's outrageous it was the
president to go down and see for himself
where people are crossing the border
illegally obviously he did not do that
the only reason why we have these people
coming across the border like we do is
because both the homeland security
secretary and the president are not in
enforcing current laws so Jesse now the
president can answer the question uh
it's not why haven't you gone to the
border so now that they feel like
they've crossed gotten over that hurdle
but it doesn't seem like there's a lot a
plan to do a lot of other things and how
can this just be a learning experience
at this point two years in everything's
a learning experience for Joe I remember
my grandmother visited me at college and
my parents said Graham was coming to
visit and to make sure everything was in
order I just remember taking everything
in my dorm room just putting it all in
the closet and she walks in I say oh
Graham you know this this is where you
study Jesse yes yes now let's get out of
here so we can get back to normal that's
what happened Joe is everyone's
grandmother that came to visit them at
college
See No Evil Hear No Evil there was one
point where I thought reality television
was real and then I was at the Jersey
Shore and I saw them filming an episode
of the Jersey Shore and I saw everybody
was out on the beach and there was a
crowd of producers around Mike The
Situation and Mike The Situation needed
a cigarette so one of The Producers goes
and just grabbed some random woman and
just pushes her next to Mike and just
she hands Mike a cigarette and they film
the whole thing and I thought to myself
this isn't a reality show this is staged
and you you see Donald Trump they said
the reality show President Joe Biden has
a fake White House set Joe Biden has
scripted pressers Joe Biden comes out
and says record inflation is zero
everything is fake now I'm not saying he
has to go and do a ride along with the
border patrol and dive into the Rio
Grande and like you know snatch a coyote
out and cuff him up that's not what you
want a fact-finding mission this was the
fact hiding Mission you want to show the
president what it's like not hide from
the president the reality of the
situation so then he can go back into
Washington and say this is what we need
to do
he did a photo op at the wall he
defunded
think about that and he thinks this is
some sort of success story look look at
him okay he defunded that wall and and a
day ago there was about 50 migrants
sitting there and then they clear them
all out and Joe Biden asked these people
well if I had a magic wand well if I
could wave a magic wand what would you
have me do well it's clear that they can
clean up the Border they did it for the
president so just enforce the law that's
already on the books that's all we're
asking you to do Joe
there's there's oh there's so many
places to take this I do think it's
interesting that the media when a
president goes somewhere they have to
cover it moderate Joe is back remember
moderate Joe this is moderate Joe it's a
learning experience will soon be a
quickly forgotten one but to his defense
I've always said this better late than
never which is also the motto for Joe's
morning BM but it's good I just hate the
fact
that they act like this was a hard thing
to do like he's got a full plate the
only thing he has on his plate is jello
fact is he's not taken a connecting
flight like out of Chicago he's not
going through TSA LaGuardia he has his
own plane what took him so long and I
think it's fair to say and you're right
arresting migrants why how could that be
because they're illegal you're not
supposed to say that until a president
comes to town and then suddenly they
become illegal they weren't illegal
before so this could so the laws do not
apply for the people that live there
only when the president arrives that's
garbage the law should be enforced when
everybody's there even if the laws suck
and I have an analogy and I think it
might be better than your grandmother
one I think it's better go for it the
Biden cleanup is just like what lousy
tenants do when they move out in order
to save their deposit right you know to
get the Fresh coat of paint over the
blood stains you go to they go to
Albertsons and rent the Giant giant
special vacuum yeah that like that
sup hair and teeth but the worst thing
about this is is that he's doing it out
in the open we're all watching this
we're the landlords and we're seeing him
do this we're watching the whole theater
as you say this is all like drama and
then when anybody asks him all
everybody's going to say it's what do
you mean look around it's spotless
everything's in place the Border it's
efficient everything's going going crazy
and he'll get away with it because the
media doesn't care Oh on I think it was
on Friday he blamed the murder of a
police officer on April 2nd you know
three months after January 6th on
January 6th he the killing of Billy
Evans was by a radical uh Nation of
Islam follower
ran them over in a car and he blamed it
on insurrectionism and I think it was
only the New York Post that covered that
so he's going to be able to actually
walk away with this because the media
will to answer your question in a
long-winded way we'll do whatever he
wants so I actually just moved out of an
apartment and I did a lot of touch-ups
and the new tenants have complained
because it's good enough and now I might
have to what were your touches I'm
curious paint touch-ups but they said
there was a lot of holes in the plaster
that required like spackling
yeah I don't think he could spackle
Jessica it is interesting for a
president to not be curious as to why
does everyone think that my Department
of Homeland Security secretary should
resign I mean there are it's there's
multiple calls for it from across the
the government obviously it's the Border
towns in particular or border states
saying like this guy is not doing his
job but Joe Biden's like I think he's
good
well you have to wonder what's going on
behind the scenes in this we know that
Joe Biden pays attention to what's going
on what people are saying about him we
know that he's expressed concerns about
Kamala Harris's performance and been
angry that it seems to be bringing down
the whole kind of reputation of the
administration that she's a weak Link in
that
um so I'm sure that he is concerned
especially heading into now a
republican-controlled Congress that he
might be facing impeachment hearings
with secretary mayorkis whatever
investigations are going to do into him
and his family and I know we're going to
talk about that later in the show but it
does feel to me and I appreciate that
Greg said better late than never not The
Poop part of that but just the general
political point for The Poop part I
believe that truly and the audience
knows that that is the thing you feel
most passionate about
um stop moving the goal posts on it
right people said go to the Border he
went to the Border you know four hours
okay what do you want six hours he's
walking around he was meeting the people
who are actually patrolling there he
didn't accuse anyone of whipping any
migrants right he said what do they need
they need more money I'm going to get
them the money that they need you should
apologize to them you brought it up no
more goal post moving until the B blocks
don't Republicans accuse them of
whipping yeah okay we don't have we
don't have a comparison for that Jessica
and you brought it up so I have to just
interject and say that's not a goal post
mover that was a requirement of the
president who demeaned uh actual
American citizens which presidents
aren't supposed to do and even you would
agree to that I I would just one thing
quickly
um
so that sheet that paper that Abbott
delivered to him and had like five
demands on it and I would say that
Governor Abbott is very good at these
kinds of
stunts frankly when you look at what was
actually listed as the things that he
wanted them to happen so the first thing
is something that no president has ever
done before Republican or Democrat so to
actually read the law that in such a way
that everyone should be detained versus
paroling anyone how is Governor Abbott
thinking that we're going to detain even
if we had a million less migrants then
this request a fully enforced title 42
that's happening plus the fact that
Biden now has a deal with Mexico also
Biden should aggressively prosecute
illegal entry and also expel everyone I
don't think that's possible at the same
time if you'd like to prosecute someone
they have to be in your country all
right so grandstanding Governor Abbott
I mean does it count if you go to the
border and you completely eliminate
something with a Lie by erasing the
problem from the streets of El Paso and
acting like that's the issue I mean if
you want to a lesson in government
propaganda 101 look at exactly what they
did ahead of Joe Biden's visit to to
this place he went to a processing
center didn't meet with any actual
migrants to ask them about maybe what
what's happening at the border they
completely moved out the town and it's
disrespectful to the border patrol and
that's why morale is down but it's also
disrespectful to the Democrat officials
in El Paso who've been begging him to go
see the problem I mean this is not
acceptable from the federal government
to go in and wipe this away and act like
this is actually the picture of what's
Happening that is a lie that is not true
just like saying the agents which the
migrants that was also a lie that they
continue to perpetuate because they
haven't apologized for it looking
forward the National Security advisor
Jake Sullivan was asked today about
President Biden's meeting with Mexican
president he didn't bring up the word
cartel a single time but he did bring up
the issue of climate change and the
bigger picture here is that the Mexican
Government is actually very corrupt they
are in bed with the cartels which is why
whenever we talk about going into Mexico
or doing what Congressman Matt Walsh
once wants to do Waltz wants to do with
allowing there to be military force that
we can use against the cartels Mexican
government gets really touchy and says
well it's about our sovereignty oh
really it's all about you guys it's not
about the Mexican Government it's not
going after the cartels be a great
question and that's exactly why they
don't want to go after it and I'm
telling you if they don't get under
control you're seeing American citizens
going to the Border getting paid off by
the cartels to do their work it will
bleed into other aspects like government
officials and it will be just like
Mexico along the border which cartels
already have control of I felt like it
was as if a president showed up six
months after a natural disaster and said
wow it's really bad yeah I thought maybe
we should do something here good thing
that came and learned all about it
everyone or Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now